>> Tucker: HIGHER EDUCATION IN
AMERICA IS CRUSHINGLY EXPENSIVE.
COLLEGE TUITION RATES ARE RISING
FAR HIGHER THAN FAMILY INCOME
IS.
COLLEGES ARE ALSO MONTHLY
CHROMATIC.
WHEN THEY COME HOME, THEY MAY
LEARN TO HATE THE VALUES HE RACE
THEM WITH, THE ONES YOU BELIEVE
IN AND THEY WILL ALSO BE
ADDICTED TO DRUGS AND ALCOHOL.
THE COST OF COLLEGE ARE
EXTRAORDINARILY HIGH.
IT'S WORTH IT WE TELL OURSELVES
FOR THE EDUCATION.
EDUCATION IS KEY.
OUR KIDS NEED TO LEARN.
THE QUESTION IS, ARE THEY
LEARNING?
SEVERAL YEARS AGO, A PAIR OF
ACADEMIC RESEARCHERS DECIDED TO
FIND OUT.
THEY STUDY DATA FROM A GROUP OF
MORE THAN 2,000 STUDENTS
ENROLLED IN FOUR-YEAR COLLEGES
WHO HAVE BEEN TRACKED OVER A
PERIOD OF YEARS.
THE BOOK OF RESULTS FROM ALL
THIS RESEARCH WAS CALLED
ACADEMICALLY ADDRESSED.
LIMITED LEARNING ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES.
AMONG ITS MANY FINDINGS, 45% OF
STUDENTS "DID NOT DEMONSTRATE
ANY SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENT IN
LEARNING OVER THE FIRST TWO
YEARS OF COLLEGE" CLOSE TO
40 PERCENT DIDN'T LEARN ANYTHING
AT ALL OVER FOUR YEARS.
HOW DO STUDENTS LEARN SO LITTLE?
MANY OF THEM NEVER ACTUALLY
STUDIED.
35% OF STUDENTS REPORTED
SPENDING NO MORE THAN FIVE HOURS
A WEEK IN ACADEMIC PREPARATION.
OVERALL, THE STUDY FOUNDED 50%
DECLINED -- THE AVERAGE
FULL-TIME COLLEGE STUDENT NOW
SPENDS ONLY 2.76 HOURS A DAY ON
ALL EDUCATION RELATED TO ACTIVIT
ALL EDUCATION RELATED TO ACTIVIE
ALL EDUCATION RELATED TO ACTIVIS
ALL EDUCATION RELATED TO ACTIVI
ACTIVITIES.
MULTIPLY THIS BY AN ENTIRE
COUNTRY AND YOU WIND UP WITH A
DEEPLY IGNORANT POPULATION.
THERE HAS BEEN A CONSISTENT
DECLINE IN ADULT LITERACY IN
AMERICA OVER THE PAST 25 YEARS
DESPITE THE FACT THAT MORE KIDS
THAN EVER ARE GOING TO COLLEGE.
TWO SEPARATE STUDIES FOR THE
NATIONAL ADULT LITERACY FIND
THAT GRADUATES FALL BELOW
PROFICIENCY.
THE MAJORITY COULD NOT COMPETE
DOMESTIC COMPLETE
SIMPLE COGNITIVE TASKS.
31% OF GRADUATES COULD READ AND
UNDERSTAND A COMPLEX BOOK.
COLLEGE GRADUATES SHOW THEY ARE
FAR MORE IGNORANT THAN THEIR
COUNTERPARTS IN VIRTUALLY EVERY
OTHER NATION.
IN SOME CASES, COLLEGE GRADUATES
IN THIS COUNTRY GOT THE SAME
TEST SCORES AS HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES IN OTHER COUNTRIES.
THE EDUCATIONAL TESTING SERVICE
PUT -- THIS IS A CRISIS.
YOU WOULD THINK THAT COLLEGES
WOULD RESPOND BY INCREASING
ACADEMIC RECORDS.
THE OPPOSITE HAS HAPPENED.
THE TOP PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES IN
AMERICA FOUND THAT ONLY NINE
SCHOOLS FUNDED IN ECONOMICS
COURSE.
ONLY FIVE REQUIRED A SURVEYS
COURSE IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
AS ONE RESEARCHER NOTED, DESPITE
LIP SERVICE GIVEN TO ALL
TOURISM, FEWER THAN HALF
REQUIRED INTERMEDIATE STUDY OF A
FOREIGN LANGUAGE.
THE NUMBER OF DEGREES AWARDED IN
WOMEN'S AND GENDER STUDIES
INCREASED BY MORE THAN 300%
SINCE 1990.
COLLEGE CLASSES ARE GETTING
FLIMSY YEAR.
COLLEGE GRADUATES ARE GETTING
DUMBER, BUT YOU WOULD NEVER KNOW
IT FROM THEIR GRADES WHAT YOU'RE
GETTING HIGHER.
IN 1983, THE COLLEGE GPA AVERAGE
WAS 2.8, IT'S NOT OVER 3.1.
IT'S MOSTLY FOUND IN PRIVATE
SCHOOLS.
IN WAKE FOREST NORTH CAROLINA,
THE CUMULATIVE GPA FOR
GRADUATING SENIORS IN 1988 WAS
2.84.
NATIONALLY, THE MOST COMMON
GRADE GIVEN IN COLLEGE COURSES
RIGHT NOW IS AN A.
ACCORDING TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," A QUARTER
OF ALL GRADES GIVEN ARE As.
IN OTHER WORDS, MORE STUDENTS
ARE FEELING, YET NOBODY FAILS.
KIDS NO LESS, BUT THEIR TEACHERS
ASSURE THEM THEY KNOW MORE.
YEAR THEY INCREASE THEIR FEES.
TRY THAT AND A PRIVATE BUSINESS,
YOU MIGHT GET INDICTED FOR
FRAUD.
WOULD AN AMERICAN UNIVERSITY,
AND YOU COULD BILLIONS IN
TAXPAYER SUBSIDIES.
MARK ROOSEVELT AS THE PRESIDENT
OF ST. JOHN'S COLLEGE IN
SANTA FE.
IT'S ONE OF THE ONLY COLLEGES IN
NORTH AMERICA WHO IS PROVIDING A
TRADITIONAL LIBERAL ARTS
EDUCATION.
MARK ROOSEVELT JOINS US TODAY.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: I WANT TO TALK TO
YOU SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE I THINK
THIS IS NOT TO PROMOTE YOUR
SCHOOL, BUT I THINK ST. JOHN'S
IS DIFFERENT FROM MOST
UNIVERSITIES.
YOU'VE GOT AN ADVANTAGE.
LOOKING AT THE COUNTRY, HOW DOES
IT HAPPEN THAT WHEN MORE PEOPLE
ARE COMING TO COLLEGE THAN EVER
BEFORE, THERE IS A CONSISTENT
DECLINE IN ADULT LITERACY?
HOW DOES THAT HAPPEN?
>> FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ST. JOHN'S TO JOIN THIS
CONVERSATION.
WE BELIEVE IN CONVERSATIONS AND
CIVIL DISCOURSE AND THAT'S
ANOTHER THING AS YOU POINTED OUT
THAT UNFORTUNATELY HAPPENS.
>> Tucker: I AGREE.
>> YOU NOTED WE WERE DIFFERENT,
WE ARE SO DIFFERENT.
WE MAY BE THE MOST RIGOROUS
COLLEGE IN AMERICA.
OUR FRESHMAN LEARN ANCIENT
GREEK, OUR SENIORS STRUGGLE WITH
QUANTUM PHYSICS.
ALONG THE WAY, THEY HAVE TO TAKE
CALCULUS, THEY HAVE TO LEARN HOW
TO DO DIFFERENTIAL EQUATIONS AND
THEY HAVE TO STUDY KARL MARX AND
ADAM SMITH.
WE ARE FAILING AGAINST ALMOST
PREVAILING AT --
I AGREE WITH WHAT YOU SOW IN THE
BEGINNING IS THAT THERE HAS BEEN
SLIPPAGE AND RIGOR, SLIPPAGE AND
DEMANDS ACADEMICALLY MADE OF
STUDENTS.
WE THINK THAT IS A MISTAKE.
WE HAVE NO INTENTIONS OF DOING
THAT PARTICULAR PARADE IN HIGHER
EDUCATION.
>> Tucker: GOOD FOR YOU, MAYBE
I'M MISREADING THIS, BUT AS THE
OUTCOMES DECLINE, BECOME LESS
THEY GRADUATE, YOU WOULD THINK
COLLEGES WERE TURNING OUT PEOPLE
WHO DIDN'T KNOW VERY MUCH, ONLY
30%.
A COMPLEX BOOK.
MAYBE WE SHOULD TEACH THEM MORE.
THE OPPOSITE SEEMS TO BE
HAPPENING.
WHY?
>> I'M NOT SURE I KNOW THE
ANSWER TO WHY.
THE MOVEMENT TOWARDS ALLOWING
STUDENTS TO SHAPE THEIR OWN
CURRICULUM AND TO BE ABLE TO
DETERMINE THEIR OWN EDUCATION IS
PART OF IT.
A LACK OF EXPECTATIONS IS
ANOTHER PART OF IT.
AGAIN, NOT TO RETURN TO
ST. JOHN'S, BUT THAT'S WHAT I
KNOW BEST, OUR STUDENTS READ 200
BOOKS AND I MEAN 200 SERIOUS
BOOKS OVER THE COURSE OF THEIR
EDUCATION.
IN ALL HONESTY, WE HAVE ABOUT
800 STUDENTS.
OUR STUDENTS ARE VERY -- THEY
KNOW WHAT THEY'RE GETTING INTO
AND THEY KNOW HOW HARD IT'S
GOING TO BE.
THAT IS A VERY, VERY SERIOUS
CHALLENGE.
>> Tucker: MAYBE YOU PUT YOUR
FINGER ON IT.
WHAT YOU'RE OFFERING IS A
TRADITIONAL EDUCATION WHICH
WOULD BE FAMILIAR TO A LOT OF
WELL EDUCATED AMERICANS.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT PERCENTAGE
OF THE AMERICAN POPULATION IS
REALLY SUITED FOR, INTERESTED
IN, SHOULD PARTICIPATE IN A
LIBERAL ARTS EDUCATION?
>> I BELIEVE THERE SHOULD BE A
LOT OF DIVERSITY.
YOU TALKED PREVIOUSLY ABOUT
CAREER PREPARATION AND THERE IS
A PLACE FOR THAT.
THERE'S A PLACE FOR PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO GET TRAINED TO DO A JOB.
WE KNOW FROM COLLEGES THAT ONLY
ABOUT 20% OF STUDENTS WHO WORK
ON SOMETHING THAT THEY MAJORED
IN AND YOU MAY KNOW, WE DON'T
HAVE MAJORS AT ST. JOHN'S.
WE DON'T THINK THAT LIFE BREAKS
DOWN INTO MAJORS.
AGAIN, WE ARE JUST VERY
DIFFERENT.
THE LIBERAL ARTS EDUCATION CAN
BE DESCRIBED AS VERY DIFFERENT
THINGS IN VERY DIFFERENT PLACES.
AT ST. JOHN'S, IT'S NOT
REQUIRED.
EVERYONE IS TAKING ALL THE SAME
COURSES AND THEY ARE ALL EQUAL
RIGOR AND DEMANDS.
THEY ARE VERY SMALL CLASSES.
AN AVERAGE OF ABOUT 15 STUDENTS,
THERE IS NO PLACE FOR THEM TO